welcome to this video playing super
cheese super cheese 7 from australia and
the French tirage it is yeah let's
develop him I recently saw a book well
oops okay now we got something entirely
different saw a book where and it was
suggested not to play an early e5 and
said play with c3 and that's a neat
trick if he plays Knight f6 this Bishop
e7 with this trick dozens of games have
been lost already check ok so how to how
to play this precisely I probably should
cancel out yeah
hmm interesting
yeah I was more thinking would hook a be
eight but maybe I can really just take
the second pawn okay Queen a6 I could
have played quicker what else now he's
some he must think about 95 95 96 okay I
guess all the way back is the best so
how to play c3 oh yeah probably c 3 i'd
i would very much like to have a night
on on d 3 Ozzie form okay yeah maybe
twinsies phone let's let's get rid of
the Queen's okay can he can move the
Queen avoid the trade but
it's not helping in much I can threaten
I def 70 it's not reacting to it at all
okay maybe I'm not threatening it now
hmm
yeah it's not really working taking them
so what should I do let's fix this
weakness only five yeah i'm a bit behind
in development but i don't really see
her how he should exploit it
I have some further improving moves like
Age 3 and end and the like ok so it
seems that she tries to play c5 after
all ok should I play 93-yard I could
also move the queen with the nights you
for coming yeah maybe
yeah peanut supply okay six what else
I'm a bit why didn't you play okay six I
don't know
no idea why I didn't play that didn't
really see him a great continuation I
mean I am born up everything's nice but
I didn't really see him direct wind on
how I could could finish the game
quickly yeah cannot play 5c a design
yeah that's no good move ready nergy 626
bloody resigns yeah this is just an
exchange dawn and game yeah I didn't you
play okay 60 in hard to tell today will
look something of course I can I can do
that this was my plan but you know I
mean this is obviously quite good for
white but I didn't think it's it's like
directly winning because these palm
pants are good but I cannot easily um
yeah I cannot easily advance them don't
see how so what is some what is my plan
I I need to prepare the slowly after
giving up the exchanger it was just
probably a direct one yeah this is a
funny funny little trickier like needs
to to Castle first and and then play
Knight f6 okay thanks for watching